hey everyone this is Steve with collider
and I am here at Sundance in our uh
studio and I really want to give a hug
and you've heard me say this again and
again but I really want to give a huge
thank you to filmo for being our sponsor
this year I love being able to Champion
Indie Cinema and the only reason we get
to be here is because of sponsors like
you guys and normally I give this big
speech explaining things but why don't
you actually say what film EO is about
sure so filo is a decentralized film
making ecosystem and it places the power
of Hollywood in the hands of creators
and fans so essentially we're handing
the power to Greenlight films into the
hands of creators and fans to work
together and collaborate so the audience
is a part of the film making process
before the film gets made so it could be
more successful and obviously if you
look at the sign behind you can see
film. is the website please visit and
support but I really sincerely thank you
because we really wouldn't be here
without people like you you know no
we're we're we're glad and you're a
great partner because you have a very
similar ethos as us that fans are really
important and and collaboration and um
yeah we're we're excited to be here with
you so jumping into why I get to talk to
you sir um would you like to explain
what is sitting on the table and what
you have been working on sure so these
are uh stop motion puppets actually so
we are just finishing up do finishing
the post right now on a film called sore
City and we did it all in stop motion
and so these are some of the actual
characters we use that we actually
animated with so you can see various
hands of the of the characters here we
have a couple different mouth
Expressions the faces are 3D printed and
then the bodies themselves we make out
of silicone and foam and uh metal
basically whatever the the the puppet
calls for is is what we need to do in
order to get the animation we need so so
one of the things is um I have been to
uh many places that have done stop
motion and generally speaking they are
smaller than this uh when it comes to
stop motion so I'm curious how did you
decide on this size for your puppets so
the reason we went this way was because
there's only so small you can 3D print
certain things and so what we do
actually is we have a builtin
infrastructure in inside with like the
eyeballs and the eyelids all that is one
mechanism for the animator cuz we were
going for ease of use because when
you're independent filmmaker you have to
go as fast as possible right you're
trying to cruise through because you
only have a you know so much money that
you can use so so there was only there's
only so small you can 3D print these
little mechanisms so that's why we had
to go with this size because this was
about as small as we could get
unfortunately so it's basically like I'm
animating a toddler every day when I was
in the on set so no one actually will
know no one has seen it yet there's no
footage so how have you been describing
the film to friends and family um
essentially it's of the story is
actually an adoption story I adopted
both of my children and I wanted to
create a story that kind of uh
celebrates birth parents who who make
the choice to play place their children
for adoption now making that jump to
this is some people think it's a little
strange but what we wanted to do was
take this kind of heavy you know heart
heartwarming theme and put it into a fun
adventure you know Pixar's synonymous
with doing that they take these kind of
heavy themes heavy stories and they and
they plug them into these really fun
adventures so that's what we did too um
the story itself is actually uh the
universe is set in this world with
dinosaurs and these people are actually
about the size of a mouse
and they build their Villages and cities
and structures on the backs of dinosaurs
and they do that for protection so when
you see the film these guys are actually
going to be really small right but you
can only animate something so small so
we have to build them big and then using
computer technology green screening and
things like that we're able to shrink
them down to the size that they should
be I don't know how you got dinosaurs in
an indie movie can Richard would you
like to explain this I I think it's a a
bit of a fantasy world where we kind of
smashed 11th century England in that
sort of time period with Jurassic you
know the Jurassic World of Dinosaurs and
it's actually a magical it's what Drew
Lauren and I in when we read it like the
artwork and just the idea of having
people live on the back of dinosaurs is
such a fantastic fantasy that they could
be merged together and in synonymous
they're like oh they actually live
together and they you know they they
bond so it's it's a beautiful world it's
beautiful animation it's a beautiful
story um and it's what it's what Drew
yeah there's humor and it's heartfelt
and it's warm and it's about family and
and belonging and Redemption and and
sacrifice and and adoption just a
beautiful heartwarming story kind of
like an uh I like to think of it as like
Indiana Jones and it's a Non-Stop
Adventure once it starts it's non-stop
one of the things is I saw your cast
list and you put together some really
good names talk a little bit about your
cast your voice cast and was it tough to
get any of them or did it all just did
it work out easy yeah surprisingly it
actually was easy um so our lead cast
Dennis Quaid Ron prman Emma Roberts in
fact this is Ron pran's character right
here uh Emma Roberts and uh Amy
Garcia that was amazing Tim Meadows
Julie
Ormond like nobody ever heard
of right but I think what it was is like
everyone else that has been a part of
the project you see the artwork you see
the visuals and you see what's going
into it and then the heart behind the
story
and uh people just resonate with it you
know it's a story that everyone can
relate to it's a story that uh that
children will love adults will love we
tried to make it as universal as
possible so it doesn't matter what
country you live in doesn't matter where
you are everyone's going to be able to
relate to the story I am curious um
since we are talking about filo uh how
did film EO play a role in getting this
made like what's the relationship
yeah so actually um the film came on
after we had already you know wrapped on
post and stuff like that it was more to
start building an audience and so that's
something that uh filo does really
really well is it uh allows creators to
put their work out there and start
creating fans before it hits theaters or
before it hits streaming so you actually
have a fan base for a successful movie
and so uh uh Sora city was actually um
uh put on the platform after hundreds of
other films and and it's number two on
the platform right now with the fan
support that it's garnered and so um a
lot of fans are really excited to see it
already it's only been on for a few
months and we have um like hundreds of
thousands of fan tokens staked which is
act they act as a vote to Greenlight the
film um and that has one of the highest
ghost scores which the ghost score in
filo basically acts as um a project
success fingerprint right so it's uh
takes uh fan engagement and shares and
um how people are interacting with it it
gives it this score and the higher your
go score you know the higher fan support
and engagement that you have to get it
green lit and um Nate's project is the
the second highest on the on the
platform so it's really exciting to see
this fan support and I can see why I
mean it's great cast great characters
the art if anybody sees the artwork it's
just so beautiful and it's it's a great
film so for people that are now
interested in this you're obviously
Indie but what is like do you have
what's your plan for when you might show
footage or you're going to show the
movie is it one of these things where
you're thinking about a festival or
you're thinking about showing it to
buyers like what's that game plan for
you really right now it's wrapping up
post and then showing it to buyers right
that's the that's the route we're going
um we also really like being a being you
know partnered up with film IO film
sorry film EO filo it's okay the website
film. so go to the website film.
sometime at some point I'm going to get
that right right film but but
it's so great to partner up with them
because they have the ability to create
and Garner an audience before the movie
is even finished right so so but the
approach definitely is getting a buyer
we wanted to do it completely
independently because we wanted to tell
the story the way we wanted to tell it
creative freedom exactly creative
freedom and especially the whole
adoption angle because I wanted it to be
relatable to the experience that we went
through with our children so I didn't
want to have you know a bunch of Cooks
in the kitchen or anything like that
yeah I try like a lot of people don't
really realize that and I've had this
conversation with so many people but
like if you make a movie for 5 million
you're going to have a lot more creative
freedom than if you have $100 million if
you make a movie for $50,000 you're
going to have a ton of creative
freedom like but you know you're you're
so right and for people who might not
realize you are able to tell your story
because you guys did it out of the box
you know and um and is there anything in
the film that you're especially proud of
that you got to put in it because you
know that if it was done in the studio
system like the notes would say no
effing
way um there is I think there's a
sequence right in the middle of the film
where the the main character here Ron
pran's character his name is Slade and
Slade he's basically the eyes of the
audience he doesn't understand why a
birth parent would make this choice
right he can't understand it
um and there's a sequence where he asks
one of the main characters why why are
you doing this why are you giving your
child away right and I think it's it's
one of those scenes where I don't know
that it it get it gets pretty deep into
why the decision is made and I don't
know that that would have gone through
sure right because because it gets
pretty deep into the psyche of a birth
parent right I'm I'm going to say to you
like you're dealing with themes that
most movies deal with let alone stop
motion you know and uh so I I commend
you because you know it it really is
important that films keep on pushing
boundaries and do things that other
people aren't doing you know so I I say
congrats on being able to pull this off
yeah you yeah it was it was definitely
been a labor of love I mean we've worked
on it for years and years just trying to
get it to the point where it is and lot
of lot of people have put everything
they can into making it happen and I
think it's because of the themes around
the film I think that's why it's it's
going to be successful I think it's
going to be my last question for the
three of you um but for all three of you
what are you actually most excited for
audiences to see when they finally get
to see this movie you feel that one uh
for for me personally I tested a little
bit on on a friend and her two kids and
they were nine and 13 and they saw about
20 to 30 minutes and just of that part
that they saw they said it was so
heartfelt had such warmth and depth that
it actually had a soul to them it's not
like you know they say a lot of
animations is just created to to sort of
just entertain with the big eyes and
nothing against it but they actually
felt like they were connected to these
characters and they were drawn in by
their story and that moved me to know
that we can take a film like this and
whether it be children or adults you
don't have to have kids to see this film
I think everybody's going to go on this
journey with us and into this film and
feel that they were changed by it and
that they will look at people and and
adoption and kids I I just met somebody
last night that was adopted and we were
talking about the film she's like it's
amazing I I know my birth parents now
and so I think the idea of adoption is
changed and adopting kids has changed I
think this film will kind of open up
every's eyes sure yeah does anyone else
want to add anything or yeah I mean I
mentioned it earlier but I'm really
excited for everybody to see the artwork
it's just so cool and and The Villages
there's different Villages that are
built with different themes on the back
of dinosaurs and it's just it's really
fun it's really cool and yeah I'm
excited I think
love the the the artwork that was going
to be the the thing I said it's so cool
everyone at the end of the day it comes
down the dinosaurs with the villages
right that's the thing that sells it the
most and so yeah I think that people are
just going to be blown away by some of
the the things we've created some of it
you can't do in stop motion you
shouldn't do but we did it right we
pulled it off the sets are amazing it's
a blending sort of a new technology
right it's like stop motion CGI 3D
printing it's something that really
hasn't been done before so the look and
feel people like wait is it CG is it
stop motion is it and people even who
have seen animation get a little like oh
this is really cool what what is that
yeah oh I'm I'm definitely looking
forward to seeing this I'm curious how
you pulled this off and also I like
supporting Indie Cinema like this is not
some huge budget you know Universal or
Netflix production it's you know this is
people are working on this are obviously
putting their heart and soul into it
this is like you know you know what I
mean yes yep definitely a passion
project and for us it's not just
stopping with this one film we want to
create the world of it
and continue on their story after this
journey as to what happens next with r
and Slade and you know Sasha like where
did their Journey where did their
Adventures take us on that note I'm just
going to say a huge thank you to film EO
for being our Sundance sponsor uh
sincerely I really say thank you and I
really really say good luck and congrats
and I look forward to helping you
promote this when the film uh has a home
sounds great thank you so much
appreciate for having us thank you
yeah